nice when you first uh met coco
you you wooed her with magic is that
true when you first met coco
kinda i mean you know i mean i first i
first walked up to i mean when i finally
got a chance to talk to her i opened
with is it okay if i flirt with you
you know that's a great thing to say
yeah
that is you ask if it's okay to flirt
yeah you don't you know you're not
trying to you're letting them know your
intentions guys you're single guys you
actually trying to talk to a female
ask them can you flirt that way that's a
that that doesn't offend them it's a
cool word and it lets some of your
intention now they say no
then you step off if they say yes now
it's your chance to be
charming so now i had she gave me the
green light so i started doing magic
tricks i'm not david copperfield
but i'm telling jokes i'm juggling
whatever
did you have like birds with you what
were you doing were there doves what was
what was
what kind of magic tricks slide a hand
press to digitation
two quarters out of his pocket i pulled
a couple quarters out you know just some
basic stuff you can learn and you know
lit a comic book
okay but i was completely confused but i
was very interested i wanted to see
where it went you were
you were confused yes you're like
where'd that quarter go and then that
that lured you in i love n no guy has
lured me with magic before so that was
i don't have any change i would show you
right now on network television
cable television wherever the hell we
are but
i can't do it whatever whatever whatever
i did conan it worked
it didn't work it did work yeah we're
here coco you're not performing live on
stage
uh in in hollywood and uh pl and planet
hollywood in vegas
in peep show yes and this is a lot of
you're
you're you're using a pole a lot in this
act right no
i'm not using a pole at all i thought
you were training on a pole okay no
let's get this right i
train at a place called shine fitness
because when you're in vegas you're
around so many cool performers cirque du
soleil acts
you know uh aerial uh silks that you
want to learn that since i'm
headlining the show i'm like why not
those are where they're being trained
and so i do pole fitness but i do aerial
pull
it's different it's not just like sexy
like around the the stripping pole
i'm talking i hold myself up with all my
strength
do you have a pole at home that you work
on do you practice on a pole
i've been wanting to get one they've got
the portable poles now
she's got a pole at home but
[Applause]
i couldn't resist i couldn't resist i
mean
[Music]
[Applause]
i am shutting this down and we are
clearing this studio and we're going to
start again
no i have a picture i have a picture of
me of what
we showed one picture oh this is you on
the pole there you go good lord
you look fantastic that's arrow pull and
i don't work my upper body at all
i always work my lower body but i go to
pull fitness to work my upper body and
everybody's like how do you get your abs
so shredded
we'll go to pole fitness that's what i
do you know me
likey all right so you gotta work on
those uh what's that you gotta work you
gotta go in the pool fitness oh
trust me i'm doing okay down here